SAFETY FOLLOWING THE ATTACK.
HE HAS NOW BEEN ARRESTED.
>> Bill: GOOD NEWS THERE.
VACCINATED ADULTS IN THE STATE
OF OHIO GETTING A CHANCE TO WIN
BIG, REALLY BIG.
THEY’VE ANNOUNCED A $1 MILLION
LOTTERY FOR THOSE WITH AT LEAST
ONE COVID SHOT.
THE GIVEAWAY IS OVER THE NEXT
FIVE WEEKS IN AN EFFORT TO
BOOST VACCINATIONS ACROSS THE
STATE.
THE PRIZES WILL BE FUNDED WITH
FEDERAL PANDEMIC RELIEF MONEY.
HOW GOVERNOR MIKE DEWINE WITH
THE INTENTATIVE.
I LOVE ORIGINAL THINKING.
THIS IS NOVEL.
WHY IS IT NECESSARY?
>> ONE OF THE THINGS THAT FRAN
AND I HAVE FOUND OUT AS WE’VE
TRAVELED AROUND THE STATE AND
BEEN TO OVER 40 VACCINATIONS
SITES AND TALK TO PEOPLE
GETTING VACCINATED.
YOU HAVE PEOPLE IN OHIO AND
ACROSS THE COUNTRY WHO GOT
VACCINATED AND 42% OF OUR
CITIZENS ARE NOW VACCINATED.
YOU’VE GOT PEOPLE WHO CLEARLY
ARE NOT GOING TO GET IT.
THEY HAVE EVERY RIGHT TO MAKE
THAT DECISION.
THEN YOU HAVE PEOPLE IN THE
MIDDLE.
THEY ARE THE PERSUADEABLE
PEOPLE AND PEOPLE WHO MAY HAVE
JUST PUT IT OFF.
WHAT WE FIND IS THAT PEOPLE ARE
GETTING VACCINATED IF THEY HAVE
THE CHANCE FOR SEVERAL MONTHS
TO GET IT.
THEY SAY WELL, MY SPOUSE TALKED
ME INTO IT OR MY SON BROUGHT ME
IN TODAY.
SO IT’S CLEAR THAT SOME PEOPLE
CAN BE PERSUADED AND MAYBE WE
CAN HELP KIND OF PUSH THEM
ALONG TO DO THIS BECAUSE THERE
IS NOTHING MORE IMPORTANT AS I
LOOK AT THE FUTURE OF OHIO THE
NEXT FEW MONTHS AND INTO THE
WINTER, NOTHING IS MORE
IMPORTANT TO SAVING LIVES AND
NOTHING IS MORE IMPORTANT TO
KEEPING OUR STATE MOVING
FORWARD THAN GETTING MORE AND
MORE OHIOANS VACCINATED.
>> EARLY ON REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR
IN YOUR STATE WERE ON THE COVID
THING QUITE QUICKLY WITH THE
MANDATES YOU PUT IN PLACE IN
OHIO.
IT SEEMS, HOWEVER, IF YOU WILL
GIVE A MILLION BUCKS A WEEK AND
GIVE, WHAT, FIVE FOUR YEAR
SCHOLARSHIPS AT OHIO PUBLIC
UNIVERSITY YOU ARE TRYING TO
DRIVE THE INCENTIVE.
WHAT DOES THAT SAY ABOUT THE
LACK OF WILLINGNESS OF THE
PEOPLE TO GET THE SHOT?
>> THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO DON’T
WANT IT.
THEY HAVE EVERY RIGHT NOT TO
GET IT.
WE AREN’T TALKING ABOUT THEM.
WHAT WE’RE TALKING ABOUT IS
PEOPLE WHO HAVE JUST KIND OF
DELAYED.
WE FIND PEOPLE WHO SAID YEAH, I
WAS ALWAYS GOING TO GET IT BUT,
YOU KNOW, JUST DIDN’T GET
AROUND TO IT.
OR NOW I CAN WALK IN AND GET IT
WITHOUT HAVING TO MAKE AN
APPOINTMENT.
EVERYBODY IS IN A DIFFERENT
PLACE.
SO IT’S THE PEOPLE AT THE
MARGINS THAT WE THINK THAT THIS
WILL MAYBE PUSH SOME PEOPLE
OVER.
AND LOOK, YOU CAN SAY IT’S A
WASTE OF MONEY.
I TALKED TO THE PEOPLE OF OHIO,
SOME PEOPLE WILL SAY MIKE
DEWINE IS CRAZY AND A BIG WASTE
OF MONEY.
THE REAL WASTE IS WHEN SOMEBODY
AT THIS STAGE, WHEN WE HAVE THE
VACCINE THAT WILL PRETTY MUCH
100% PROTECT YOU BUT YOU DON’T
TAKE IT, YOU GET THE COVID, AND
YOU DIE.
THAT IS A WASTE.
IT’S A TRAGIC, TRAGIC WASTE AND
THAT’S WHAT IS SOMETHING THAT
IS JUST HORRIBLE.
>> Bill: TWO MORE POINTS HERE.
FULLY VACCINATED OHIO, A BIT
ABOVE THE NATIONAL AVERAGE FOR
VIEWERS.
LOOK AT THE TOP LINE HERE, A
BIT ABOVE.
AT LEAST ONE DOSE OR SLIGHTLY
BELOW BY 4 OR 5 POINTS.
WE SEE WHAT THE NEED IS THERE.
CAN YOU USE FEDERAL DOLLARS IN
A GIVEAWAY LIKE THIS?
IS THAT LEGAL?
>> WELL, LOOK, THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
WE’VE HAD LAWYERS LOOK AT THIS
AND THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
SUPPLY THIS MONEY SO WE CAN
FIGHT COVID.
THAT’S ALL WE’RE DOING WITH
THIS.
WE’RE TRYING TO GET MORE PEOPLE
VACCINATED.
WE THINK WE WILL GET MORE
PEOPLE VACCINATED.
THAT IS FIGHTING COVID.
THE BEST WEAPON WE HAVE TODAY
TO STAY ON OFFENSE AND THAT IS
THE VACCINE.
IT IS COMING DOWN TO THE
VACCINE AT THIS POINT.
IF WE CAN GET MORE OHIOANS WHO
CAN’T SPREAD IT AND GET IT
WE’RE FIGHTING IT.
>> Bill: THE NEWS IS 12 HOURS
OLD.
HAVE YOU HEARD FROM OTHER
GOVERNORS?
>> NOT HEARD FROM ANYBODY YET.
>> Bill: ’TIS EARLY.
THANKS.
MIKE DEWINE WE’LL WATCH IT AND
SEE WHO THE LUCKY WINNERS ARE
RIGHT AND BRING THEM ON THE
SHOW.
>> 13 DAYS TO THE FIRST DAY.
>> Bill: THREE WEEKS BEFORE YOU
LIFT THE MANDATES IN OHIO.
>> Dana: WHEN I FIRST HEARD
ABOUT IT LAST NIGHT I THOUGHT
THAT WAS OUTRAGEOUS.
BUT LISTENING TO HIM TALK ABOUT
HIS RATIONALE.
I BELIEVE IN STATES BEING ABLE
TO BE INNOVATIVE AND TO GIVE IT
A TRY AND IF HE THINKS THIS IS
THE BEST WAY TO SPEND COVID
RELIEF DOLLARS TO GET PEOPLE
VACCINATED SO EVERYONE CAN GET
BACK TO WORK AND SCHOOL, MAYBE
HE HAS A POINT.
>> Bill: WE’LL SEE IF IT WORKS.